i take food
so seriously because it literally saved
my life
i needed a reason to get out of bed
every day i needed a reason to
continue to live and be and exist on
this earth and that was baking
my name is brianna jackson i'm a
professional pastry chef from
los angeles california and i'm the proud
owner and head baker
for sugar and spice baked by brie
i even started the business honestly i
was always in the kitchen with my
grandmother growing up
of course for holiday meals cooking
things with her but
when i got older and would just get
frustrated or have like a really bad day
the first thing i do is put things down
in the house and go straight to the
kitchen
and just look around in the pantry in
the fridge and say
what can i create that'll bring me joy
right now or what can i do that would
just make me happy and
it was always in the kitchen once i got
into the kitchen mostly stuck
to sweets and that's kind of what i was
most comfortable with i was
experimenting with cakes
with cupcakes especially different types
of cookies if i'm going to a friend's
party or a birthday party
i baked it was okay if you go mama
always told
you never go anywhere empty-handed so
get in that kitchen
make something and every time i went to
a function and had a dessert with me
everyone loved it and they text me oh my
god girl you did your thing in this
like wow this is amazing this is the
best dressed leches i've ever had like
just have someone tell you that it feels
amazing
there's something about food that just
it makes you happy
when you bite into it it just warms your
soul
and if i can provide that for someone
else that just fills me with joy
i knew in middle school i wanted to go
to culinary school
i unfortunately just didn't have the
privilege or the accessibility to really
pursue that it was always you know
get a traditional education first and
maybe if you're still passionate about
it then
at least you have a fallback the entire
four years i was in college all my
friends found me
in the kitchen brianna's making cookies
or briana's making cupcakes or brianna's
doing something in that kitchen everyone
just knew
food has just always been there it's
always been something i've wanted and
wanted to pursue
forever
i started sugar and spice in september
of 2016.
it's been almost four years now starting
a business
when i did especially in that time was
not at all planned
when i would do events and pop-ups and
things of that nature people would
always ask me oh my gosh like what made
you start your business how did you get
here and
i would lie and say it felt like the
right time it felt like the right thing
to do
in truth it was born out of one of the
most dramatic things that's happened to
me
sugar and spice started four years ago
and four years ago i was relearning how
to
live exist and even be any longer
it was august 4th 2016.
i was raped by someone i know
and that moment absolutely broke me
it surpassed any pain i've ever dealt
with in my life
the emotional pain the mental pain the
physical pain
it was to the point where i questioned
life i questioned
spirituality and religion and everything
and everyone like
why why me because of that
and how i dealt with it and internalized
it
and tried to move forward from it it
kind of sparked the business
i needed a purpose i needed a reason to
get out of bed every day
i needed a reason to continue to live
and be and exist on this earth and that
was baking
it's weird because i would go days
without eating
but i was still somehow cooking for
others
i was caring for my grandmother and i
may be sad
and hurt in so many ways but
my grandma's like the love of my life so
that's never going to stop me from
cooking for her
and bringing her some happiness because
in turn
it makes me a little happier i'm feeling
at my absolute lowest and my absolute
worst
but yet i'm still able to produce
something that brings others happiness
all right maybe there's something there
maybe this can
really help me and bring me a little
more joy back into my life
food has always represented security
it's been
joyful and provided a happy place for me
that was something at that point in my
life
i was really lacking and searching for
and trying to find again
i found the sanctuary and sanctioned in
the
in the kitchen before i found it in
anyone else and even myself
the kitchen was just i knew that was
always the place for me when i was
younger
so i said you know what maybe it can
help now
i have been through so much loss in my
life
and then with the rape i lost myself so
to have all these losses it's just like
i gotta find myself i need to have a win
and that win was
sugar and spice baked by bree
as traumatizing as that moment was it
was
the life change that pushed me to pursue
my passions
full-fledged full force no longer
holding back say you know i've wanted
this my entire life life is too short
to not pursue your dreams there's
nothing holding me back
and i'm going for it since then
i've developed recipes and had a dish
on a menu at a restaurant i worked at i
have been
a kitchen manager i have been
front of the house back of the house as
far as
any job within the food industry you
name it i've done it at this point
i don't think i started to feel like
myself again until i finally just
jumped into pursuing food full time my
favorite tattoo that i have
is my chef's tattoo and it's my favorite
quote from
nipt hustle find your purpose or you're
wasting air and this is my
very first chef's knife that i got my
purpose is to cook to be in somebody's
kitchen somewhere in the world
and just produce food that i love that
i'm proud of and proud to say hey i
created this
when someone's eating one of my
creations i'm just i'm profoundly just
happy
that is when i finally felt like me
i really started this journey selfishly
and this business was like a selfish
thing
for me this business helped me find
myself again
and since i've been open about it and
opening up to more people about it
now this business it's not even about me
i really hope
i can help someone else through this
journey like yeah i want you to be happy
when you taste my food but like
there's so much more to it like there's
so much more to food than people think
it is
food is life-changing
if i could talk to me four years ago
oh baby girl you are
so much stronger than you think um
you have so far to go and you are as
great as people have been telling you
your entire life
this this is the moment but it only gets
better from here
like keep please keep fighting
i think i could summarize my story in
one word and that is survival
no matter how difficult the roads have
been
how many events i've done where i might
not even sell a single thing
i'm still gonna survive i'm gonna find a
way to take that
learn from it grow from it and continue
to move forward
i love food food definitely helps me
love myself
a little harder i will never give it up
food
absolutely saved my life
my name is brianna breezy jackson proud
owner of sugar and spice baked by breed
and i'm following my food dreams
you